I don't know if there's one system in
particular I think if you look at Japan
and even China and India there's just
some amazing things going on and one of
the things i think we find in countries
like that is that teachers are so highly
valued i remember meeting a a woman in
Kansas City who is a professor of
Education and she has a scar on her calf
and she asked me one day she said you
know how I got that scar I said no she
said well when she was a girl as a
schoolgirl in Nigeria she was outside
and she encountered her one of her
teachers walking on the sidewalk and she
said in Nigeria it's customary that a
student would bow to a teacher and she
said there was a thorn bush right behind
me and I got my calf stuck on a thorn
and I thought my gosh sometimes I can
walk down the halls of my school and
never to get a student even say good
morning back when I greet them so
there's a real difference in the way we
respect teachers in this country
I just read something lately that would
suggest that down the road other
developed countries are going to become
fierce competitors in a post secondary
market and so instead of sending their
best and brightest to the United States
for college maybe someday the best and
brightest from the United States will be
going abroad to other institutions in
other countries so I think while it may
appear we have a stranglehold on this
university market I think that could
well change in the decades ahead
you